I think it is very very worrying because
we haven't had in our recent history an
example of a nationalist party but one
part of the United Kingdom playing a
part in the government of a hold of the
United Kingdom saying very frankly I'll
make admin of and Prime Minister I'll
write the first budget you can't have
Trident submarines unless you you know
we're going to cut all these other
aspects of Defense hs2 won't be built in
the way that all the parties united
kingdom up to now have agreed that's
only in 24 hours those three examples
I've just given you that I think calling
that a chilling prospect or a
frightening prospect I think that is not
an understatement a lot an overstatement
I'm afraid labour won't sign up to any
of those policy position will sign up to
a coalition but labour have been ours
you know dozens of times do you rule out
having any formal arrangements with the
SNP and they won't answer the question
in again in the last 24 hours Andy
Burnham Health's shadow health secretary
Angela Eagle shadow leader of the House
of Commons saying well let's wait and
see and I'm sure we'll talk to everybody
and perhaps there are things we can do
together I think genuinely this is a
very frightening prospect the SNP look
Nicola Sturgeon ism
deeply plausible politician and speaks
very clearly and all the rest of it
she's only got one major aim in life and
that is to break up the United Kingdom
these separatists they're not interested
in making the Westminster Parliament
stronger we ask yourself this question
does Nicola Sturgeon at the end of five
years want people to look back and go
well that was a good government in
Westminster the Western stuff
Parliament's working well for me no of
course not choose to break up the
western civ element and break up our
country but that's just minority
government the Labour have said nothing
other than if if the parliamentary
arithmetic falls like that they'd have
to consider the views of all the
minority parties that's just how it
would they they should rule they should
do a hunky which is to rule out any form
of arrangement with the snc physics what
sort of SNP MPs going through the
division are physically stop them voting
but you can stop any form of
conversation or agreement or
understanding with them because there is
no understanding you can reach with the
group of people that want to break up
your kind of hang on though when you a
conservative leader in 2007 you must
have green lighted Annabel Goldie
supporting the SNP in a minority
government in halle but there's a world
of difference because of course in the
Holyrood Parliament so that is a
parliament that the SNP thinks ought to
exist did you give permission for that
syringe I talked to animal gold will get
all those usually yes we was into a
conservative Simon minority SNP cup
there's a huge difference because the
Hollywood Parliament is something the
SNP believe it right the Western Solomon
they think should be abolished they
think the United Kingdom shouldn't exist
so this is not a group of friendly
people coming to come coming down to
Westminster with some good ideas for how
to run Britain all they want to do is to
create a set of circumstances where the
breakup of our country becomes more
likely you